An Out-of-place artifact is any historical
object that seems, at a glance, to go against
our understanding of historical chronology. Some
artifacts appear "too advanced" for the technology
of the period they were created, and seem like
they’ve fallen out of time. The exciting mystery
of these artifacts has led to a range of wild
speculation, involving everything from aliens to
time travel. As much fun as it is to think someone
with a flux-capacitor popped by and accidentally
left a cell phone in ancient Rome, most of
these objects have reasonable explanations.
But the real historical context behind these
Out-of-place artifacts and the ancient cultures
which produced them can be just as interesting
as speculative theories. So, let’s take a look at
seven of the most thought-provoking, and uncover
how such astounding artifacts were created:
The Antikythera Mechanism is an ancient Greek
object which has amazed archeologists, historians,
and classicists for decades. The artifact consists
of various incomplete bronze gear fragments
which once formed a kind of primitive machine,
sometimes described as the world’s first analogue
computer. Most archeologists believe Greek
Scientists constructed the mechanism around 87 BC.
it was discovered in a shipwreck off the coast of
Antikythera island. The technological prowess on
display wouldn’t be matched until over a thousand
years later, hence why it seems so out of place.
In truth, however, the Greeks around this period
were just that proficient with complex gear-work,
with ancient literature describing the
construction of similar devices. But, what
did this early machine do? Based on recreations,
archeologists think the mechanism was a sort of
astronomical clock, able to predict the position
of the moon and even eclipses decades in advance,
likely for the purpose of astrology and cultural
festivals. Other devices like astrolabes were used
in later centuries to make similar calculations,
but none were at the same level as the Antikythera
Mechanism for quite a while, making the
invention quite impressive — even if it
isn’t ‘out of place.’ Up next we have the Roman
dodecahedron, small hollow objects made in the
2nd to 4th centuries CE, which look quite bizarre
at a glance. The twelve-sided shapes are made of
copper, and were spread all over the roman
empire, with archeologists discovering over
a hundred since the 18th century. Funnily enough,
as far as we’ve been able to uncover, the ancient
Romans never recorded what the purpose of these
dodecahedrons were. While the lack of explanation
lends the objects a certain mysterious power,
truthfully, it’s more likely the Romans never
recorded their purpose because they were ordinary
enough everybody already knew what they were.
Archeologists have put forth various theories
regarding their usage, including dice, coin
measuring… and knitting aides but in this case,
the right answer is probably the most mundane.
Trace amounts of wax have been found inside some
of objects, suggesting the dodecahedrons were used
as candle holders. The Iron pillar of Delhi is a
metal structure now located in Delhi, India dating
back to 4th or 5th century CE. At 7.2 meters
or roughly 24 feet high, and over three tons or
6,000 pounds in weight, it’s an incredible feat
of engineering. Any normal iron pillar would have
corroded away long ago, yet the pillar of Delhi
is famous for its astonishing resistance to rust
despite being over a thousand years old. Indeed,
some have claimed that pillar is completely
rust-free, and therefore must be the result of
something beyond the realm of science. Any actual
photos of the pillar make it clear this isn’t the
case — there unmistakably is rust on the pillar,
even if it’s in unbelievable condition. The secret
to the pillar’s longevity lies in the skill of 4th
century Indian metallurgists, who constructed
the iron pillar through a complex process
involving rust resistant compounds to ensure its
survival. It’s an inspiring feat of engineering,
even if it’s not something historians somehow
‘can’t explain.’ The Stone Spheres of Costa Rica
are a collection of over 300 circular rocks with
mysterious origins. The objects are attributed to
the Diquís culture, an indigenous civilization of
Costa Rica which flourished from 700 to 1530 CE.
The spheres come in all sizes, and have a certain
mystery to them compounded by the fact that their
exact significance remains shrouded in uncertainty
— with the most popular theory proposing they were
placed in lines before the houses of rulers.
Regardless of their exact meaning, some have
suggested the spheres’ size and impressive
geometric roundness were beyond the capabilities
of the Diquís culture. Frankly, this isn’t
giving the Diquís enough credit —the civilization
was highly advanced, producing other forms of
impressive sculpture like the metal effigy you see
currently. Whatever the cultural purpose behind
the spheres, there’s no reason to suspect the
Diquís society didn’t produce them. The Maine
penny is a Norwegian silver coin dating back to
the Viking age. The coin itself is ordinary enough
— but what makes it an Out-of-place artifact
is the fact it was discovered in, well, in the
state of Maine in the United States. The coin’s
existence has been suggested as evidence a group
of Vikings made it all the way to the shores of
modern day North America during their travels.
When the coin was first discovered in 1957 the
idea Vikings ever crossed the Atlantic Ocean was
pretty new, but today, it’s a much more widely
accepted theory thanks to other forms of evidence.
While the coin itself does appear to be an actual
Viking coin, here’s still some debate as to
whether it might have be brought over by a later
traveler. There’s still some debate regarding the
coin’s authenticity, but it matches other Viking
coins minted during the period on the other side
of the ocean. Indeed, this is the one artifact on
this list where the far-out explanation is likely
the correct one — although the coin probably
started in Canada closer to Greenland and made
its way down through trade. Dogū are small statues
from Jōmon period of Japan with a distinctive
appearance. To modern observers, the statues
almost resemble a person wearing a spacesuit.
So, did an alien or a human time traveler decked
out in anachronistic gear accidentally stumble
around ancient Japan long enough to get statues
made in their likeness? Mmmaybe... but it’s
far more likely the resemblance to any modern
clothing is coincidental. If these statues
are considered in context with other versions,
you can see most Dogū look decidedly far off from
the distinctive space-suit like appearance of the
more famous figurines. Most Dogū effigies from
the surrounding period actually place emphasis on
the wide hips more than anything else, with some
lacking heads altogether. The exaggerated hips and
abdomens of these statues have led historians
to theorize the they. were in fact associated
with fertility. Maybe not as exciting as time
travel, but still pretty interesting nonetheless.
Concluding our list, we have the Eltanin Antenna,
a mysterious object photographed on the ocean
floor in the 1960s. Antarctic research ship USNS
Eltanin is the vessel which captured the strange
antenna like-artifact on camera. The ship was
traveling west of Cape Horn in South America,
when crew-members spotted the object at a
strikingly deep depth of over 3,900 meters or
12,800 ft below the ocean’s surface — in a region
close to total darkness. So, what was this alien
looking object so far below sea level? Probably
a type of sea sponge. Chondrocladia concrescens
is a species of carnivorous sponge with unusual
appendages which vaguely resembles an antenna.
A pretty wild organism, even if it’s not quite
as astounding as some deep-sea radio dish.
And that’s the end of our analysis of seven
interesting Out-of-place artifacts and the
explanations behind them. I hope you had fun
and perhaps learned something along the way.
If you did, please consider
subscribing to Curious Archive
and leaving this video a like. Thank you so much
for watching, and I’ll see you in the next video.